ok jetzt direkt mit meinem kleinen
streit angefangen hier unten dieses
video eine urheberrechtlich geschützte
tonspuren der märkte kommen zu einem
neuen für wir schon gemerkt hab ständig
durch lokalen kehrmann stimmen bewegt
fall in der union aber bevor wir mit dem
heutigen video loslegen leute es gibt
ein richtig großes feld das projekt von
dem heute die erste folge gelauncht
wurde
[Musik]
unterstützen wollte nämlich keine freude
machen wollte ein klick auf den ersten
link in der beschreibung der führt euch
direkt zu der ersten folge und las auf
jeden fall mal ein abo für den kanal dar
denn da werden in zukunft richtig fette
sachen kommen also wie gesagt erster
linke der beschreibung erst mal rüber
gehen gerne ab oder lassen dann freut
sich wer keinen job macht wirklich so
schön aber jetzt fange mit dem heutigen
video gesehen wir schauen verwirrten
ersten videos von youtube an ebenfalls
mehr habt ihr gesehen dass sich heute um
ins coaching beim und die handelt sagen
wir legen direkt ab mit ingo alter
schwede er selbst wieder für in skopje
modern warfare 2 multiplayer gameplay
hashtag ein und ist sage und schreibe 66
jahre alt das ist grad so heute
videofilmer nicht gelten also ich weil
wir alle keine in skopje heute drauf ist
also befinden wer geistig normal auf
jeden fall überhaupt keine ausfälle oder
momente in die nerven auf mich papa muss
schreibt sehr gespannt zu sehen wie
dieser mensch sich am sechsten siebten
2010 mit dem sechseinhalb jahren dieser
menschliche 6/2010 verhalten hat so auch
und die sagte hallo ich würde sagen im
ersten mit macht die stimme eigentlich
nein druck wasser bitten auffällt ist
dass hier also eigentlich gewann
aufnimmt
ja tut wird man danach nicht mehr mikro
das hat ihn ist jetzt nicht beachtet
aber sind halt auch wirklich passt wir
nennen unsere games eine bank die partie
ich halte deine nagel empathie genau so
nennen sommersession erste idee also wie
es aussieht finden sehr schöner
stationären verkauf ist natürlich immer
für den erwerber erfreulichen bietet
smart home video ich das format ist das
im kopf kumpel top und er drüber geht
also die arbeitsteilung einer top einer
rede gleich wieder ganz sicher nicht
mehr mitkämpfen halten und mit wem man
merkt auf jeden fall so die stimme von
ins cockpit eigentlich schon ganz okay
bekommen kannst du darüber natürlich
durch mega gelangweilt oder mega leise
sein und möchte dies aber aber ist für
den anfang doch eigentlich echt nicht
schlecht und das so eine sache die man
bei vielen supermärkten die wirklich
großen heutzutage hatten meistens auch
schon erste video die klar die wanderer
amateurhafter selbstverständlich aber
man merkt dass diese bitte was da ist
also das irgendwie irgendwas war damals
von damals gegen bekannte seine mutter
seine mutter stella die witze waren
bitten verbesserungswürdig aber ich
glaube so viel passiert nämlich die
video einfach nicht mehr so einfach
kommt dafür ein trip ist auch erlaubt
darüber so wichtig wie heute alle pferde
mache weiter mit juli in bern mit unsere
nummer zwei heutzutage sein erstes video
was jetzt muss ich im verein bei ja du
wie du erst mal bevor es losgeht dieses
video wurde am 19 02 2012 nicht geladen
heute haben wir nicht immer den sechsten
zweiten vermissten also für mit genau
fünf jahre alt
ich weiß gar nicht ob eine video mehr
verfehlt aber die bewegung an sich sind
so
[Musik]
bitte bitte dafür sieht aus wie viel
charakter vom gefährt unter gefallen hat
einfach eine gummiartige waffel matte 11
und bestätigen könnten blieben und
werfen hier lust bereits ist rein
sportlich rein athletisch schon richtig
heftig was er da abliefert er will
einfach draußen wirklich behindert und
dann schmeißt er einfach keine eigenen
körper weg steht oder sitzt da und
schmeißt einfach dein körper in
irgendeine richtung fängt es wieder ab
so die dreifache backflip auch von einer
hand und dann schmeiße sein körper lag
wieder weg okay was können
zusammenfassend sagen für juli in bern
auf jeden fall ist ein video ein was
anders ist als die meisten wege wie
lange die meisten leute haben mir euro
mit pocken angefangen natürlich ewig
betrieben kommen jetzt bereit erwarteten
nummer drei am heutigen tage und das ist
okay das sind auf jeden fall nie gesehen
habt stellt das video heißt die journey
minecraft music video okay jetzt direkt
mit meinem kleinen zwei eingefangen
hatten sich über tief videoaktiv eine
urheberrechtlich geschützte tonspuren
aufgrund des anspruchs urheberrechte
hubbard wurde die tonspur endgültig
sturm bescheid heißt diese minecraft
music video keine musik zu hören und
zwar minecraft biederen hashtag 1 vom 26
07 2011 also auf viereinhalb jahre alt
[Musik]
dass das erbe schrift in der luft spielt
auf und michael fink war vermutlich vor
viereinhalb jahren schon ziemlich krass
ist heute immer noch nicht wie es geht
aber ich bin ja auch nicht stehen sie im
ersten moment ganz aus dem nichts sagen
und noch eigentlich echt ungewöhnlicher
konnte dafür der platz vor 400 jahren
kam kopenhagen haben eigentlich alle
noch ohne shader ohne irgendwas einfach
nur minecraft motto hunger games folge
32 und das funktioniert aber steht jetzt
schon mal damit auf seine eigene ideen
es wird scho glei schon sagen nur die
köpfe alles ganz geil hat sehr gut zu
dem was für die video präsentiert wird
als einfach mit coole idee also wie
gesagt alle anleihen gefolgt von stinky
ich bau mir im parcours in irgendeinem
mycroft wettlauf das pärchen durchmachte
bisschen fertig mit den schwarzen balken
rum und unten passt irgendwie zu ihm
würde ich sagen ohne trainerschein
filmen hatte das gar nicht gesehen wo
ich stehen geblieben ist das glaube ich
bin die wand gekommen ich meine findet
sich ja sogar war das damals noch keine
sprinterin minecraft besser muss immer
doppelt weh drücken wird schon geil das
schon geil abschaltung des möglich video
da würde ich das erste video ist was man
von dem etwas sehen kann dass hier lohnt
ich glaube ich schon dass anzuschauen
als jetzt gefühl steger hat eigentlich
genauso wie wehner nun ganz gutes
händchen für stimmungen stimmung anfangs
zu erfolgen und das ist seine sache
mega viel aufwand betrieben dafür dass
wir so alte aber keine ting ist es fällt
auf dass vor dem heutigen video dann
bist du schon so weit ich war heute viel
eingeschlagen krank nicht so fehlt
ansonsten habe ich euch hier oder hier
die erste volkszählung 9 format mit
youtube medien und heute gestartet ist
auf jeden fall sehr fettig davon ab und
das gern aber von mir da ansonsten wirst
du nächsten mal daumen nach oben zeigt
und tschüss